[Musique]
deux cent quinze femmes sur 577 députés
ont été élus dimanche dernier aux
élections législatives un nombre en
baisse par rapport à 2010 cette voie si
l'assemblée constituante en 1945 les
femmes acquièrent le droit de vote et le
droit d'être élu cette nouvelle
assemblée est donc un brin plus féminine
chez picquier sf bio dans la cour du
palais monsieur edouard herriot
président du parti radical
jean louis marc
et puis des femmes des communistes et
des socialistes des femmes députées oui
mais en 1945 on se passe bien les
présenter pourtant cette année-là 33
femmes entrent à l'assemblée au début de
la vème république à partir de 1958 le
pourcentage des femmes députées peine à
dépasser les 2% de l'hémicycle une très
légère augmentation est amorcée fin des
années 70 et dans cette assemblée il y à
473 homme si j'ai bien compté et 18
femmes seulement c'est encore peu mais
c'est mieux quand 73 tout de même c'est
vrai c'est un peu mieux mais le nombre
de femmes députées semble être bloqué
par un plafond de verre pendant des
décennies c'est toujours difficile pour
toute minorité d'exister et nous ne
sommes que 34 sur 577 à l'assemblée
nationale au niveau des assemblées
nationales nous sommes en gros 5 %
depuis la libération et nous n'arrivons
pas à décoller le décollage a lieu fin
des années 90 début des années 2000
quand la parité devient un sujet de
débat au sein même de l'hémicycle
aujourd'hui pour une fois on ne voyait
qu'elle les femmes ne sont que 60 à
l'assemblée mais on discute de la parité
alors elles tiennent la vedette la
parité est inscrite dans la constitution
et des lois sont votées la part des
femmes à l'assemblée augmente 10 12 18%
mais trop lentement il faut une
politique contraignante notre pays est
lanterne rouge en europe au 21e rang
devant l'italie mais très loin derrière
la suède l'allemagne ou l'espagne pour
que la politique ne reste pas une
affaire d'hommes
le projet augmente les amendes si la
parité n'est pas respectée mais certains
partis préfèrent sortir le carnet de
chèques plutôt que de féminiser leurs
candidats comme pour les législatives de
chaque année l'ump perd ainsi plus de 4
millions d'euros pour non respect de la
parité une amende qui dissuade certains
partis le front national va ainsi
présenter 51 % de femmes les socialistes
les verts et le front de gauche sont
aussi à l'équilibré en 2012 et 2017 la
part des femmes augmente pour
redescendre légèrement à ces dernières
élections de 2022 la parité au palais
bourbon n'est donc toujours pas une
réalité
[Musique]